bonjour frédéric saint clair merci de
répondre à nos questions sur arte france
comment est ce que vous avez accueilli
le discours hier des manuels macron la
réouverture des crèches des écoles très
certainement bien accueillie par les
parents pour le 11 mai mais est ce que
ça ne risque pas de prêter des
discussions d'ordre sanitaire
oui j'ai accueilli avec beaucoup de
prudence et je pense que je pense que le
président d'ailleurs là l'a explicité
dans son dans son discours il a l'a
divisé son discours en deux parties une
première partie qui était une réponse à
la question où en sommes-nous avec une
dimension empathique pour les personnels
qui sont en première ligne et deuxième
ligne et puis avec une dimension
politique où il a commencé à défendre
déjà son bilan en anticipant le moment
où il va nous falloir réellement faire
un vrai bilan de la gestion de cette
crise et puis la deuxième partie qui
découpe est elle aussi en en dessous
partie avec la première grande
information c'est à dire une date à
laquelle il va falloir relancer
l'économie du pays avec la santé c'est
la deuxième grande composante impacté
dans cette crise et donc chaque fois que
la réflexion politique se pose elle se
pose en deux termes qui sont placés de
chaque côté de la balance santé publique
économie et la date du 11 mai n'est rien
d'autre qu'une date où ils anticipent un
déconfinement possible si jamais la
décrue en tout cas l'absence de
croissance des cas admis en réanimation
l'autorisent ça veut dire qu'il faut
prendre cette date là avec beaucoup de
précaution mais psychologiquement les
français en avaient besoin et je pense
que c'était l'idée générale de cette
allocution était de donner un horizon de
court terme disons aux français et aux
entreprises
vous dites qu'il faut prendre cette date
du 11 mai avec avec précaution justement
ce matin christophe castaner nuance un
le déconfinement le 11 mai n'est pas une
certitude mais un objectif
comment est-ce qu'il faut accueillir
cette déclaration du ministre de
l'intérieur au lendemain
la quatrième allocutions présidentielles
des manuels de macron depuis le début de
cette crise oui pour le coup je crois
qu'il précise assez bien la pensée du
président c'est à dire que c'est un
objectif c'est à dire que emmanuel mais
est ce que c est ce que c'est pour que
les français comprennent bien ne fasse
pas tout de suite des conclusions
hâtives parce que c'est pour rectifier
le tir par rapport à l'allocution d'hier
pour dire attention c'est pas sûr encore
que ce soit le 11 mai c'est ça je crois
qu emmanuel macron à a été précis dans
son dans son allocution pour le coup sur
ce point là en expliquant que à
condition que le confinement demeure
aussi stricte qu'est ce qu'il est en ce
moment avec un nom parents forcément
mais pas non plus un allègement des
mesures et que les choses se passent
pour le mieux dans les hôpitaux on peut
anticiper raisonnablement une date du 11
mai pour adé confinement mais à ce
moment-là ça suppose quoi ça suppose que
ceux des confinement soit pensée il l'a
annoncé il va y avoir des prises de
parole des différents ministres pour
articuler la façon dont ceux des
confinement peut se faire on comprend
bien quand il parle des écoles on
comprend bien et d'ailleurs je mélenchon
l'a souligné que c'est parce qu'il a
besoin de remettre les parents au
travail tant que vous gardez les enfants
à la maison
mais les parents ne peuvent pas
reprendre leurs emplois et à ce
moment-là l'économie ne repart pas donc
c'est vraiment compliqué aussi de
retourner à l'école je pense notamment à
la distanciation social parmi les élèves
kantienne classe de 25 c à blaye place
pour justement mettre les élèves assez
loin les uns des autres
ça va être compliqué tout ça mais bien
sûr que c'est compliqué et et ses 1 c1
c'est un vrai pari sanitaire c'est à
dire que on peut se retrouver deux
semaines après avoir repris l'école dans
une situation de blocage où on est
obligé de redemander au aux élèves dans
certaines régions de reprendre donc quel
est le calcul le calcul c'est on regarde
les départements où le le nombre de cas
est vraiment au minimum et à ce moment
là on sait que le risque est également
lui aussi minimum et qu'il ne va pas y
avoir deux
au delà de la contagion au moment où les
élèves vont retourner à l'école imaginez
bien que dans l'île de france et dans
grand test
il n'y aura pas de déconfinement et de
reprise de l'école le 11 mai c'est
absolument certain
dernière question rapidement vous avez
parlé à des dimensions politiques
sanitaires coûte de la dimension
économique du discours d' emmanuel
macron il à dire bâtir notre économie
garder notre indépendance financière
ça traduit quoi exactement alors que ce
matin bruno le maire annonce une
prévision à -1 8 % en 2020 pour le pib
français
ça traduit un effondrement économique
majeur mais également mondiale donc la
vraie question c'est qui se relève le
premier qui va tirer les marrons du feu
au niveau économique qui va être capable
de faire repartir la production de la
consommation dans un premier temps
ensuite dans un second temps c'est quid
du monde d'après emmanuel macron a pris
date
il a dit je reviendrai vous parler de ce
monde d'après il a parlé de cette
nécessité de se réinventer alors on a
glosé sur l' usage du terme mais
globalement ce qu'il est en train de
nous annoncer c'est que il anticipe une
modification de son idéologie
néolibérale pour l'adapter aux
contraintes du moment jusqu'à où il va
être capable d'aller il n'a pas apporté
de réponse et c'est la vraie question
parce qu'en matière d'économie c'est à
dire se projeter dans un avenir avec une
économie nouvelle qui n'est plus ce
mondialisme libéralisé ça pose un
certain nombre de questions il va
falloir qu'il y réponde et ses mots de
la fois remercie frédéric à 5h d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes analyste en stratégie et en
communication politique